so i want to congratulate you guys on
the upcoming season three it is amazing
um so as seasoned pros of this show you
know how has it been writing harley and
seeing how she changes and grows because
obviously we know comic book characters
time kind of reset at the end of their
arcs typically but she's really we've
really seen her sort of evolve and how's
that been
yeah that's that's one of the most fun
parts about this show is like you know
we come from episodic television like we
that's where we made our bones in
network tv and and it is very much a
reset after every episode so we were
really excited to kind of take this
uh character in a different place each
season build on what we did before
um and yeah i think that's been for me
at least one of the most rewarding
things about riding harley yeah i mean
the big thing with this season was you
know given the way that season two ended
with you know it's firmly establishing
that harleivy is a thing they are a
couple we were like well this is of
course what we want to explore this
season
and we thought you know like we we've
constantly kind of banged this drum of
like these two are now never going to
break up and
as long as we are running the show they
will never break up um
so hopefully this won't air after we're
fired
for whatever reason we will riot
um but yeah i presented this really
interesting challenge of like how do you
um create uh sort of drama between these
two knowing that you know at the end of
the day they're rock solid um and so we
sort of
used um
i guess harley's discovery this season
of like
where she kind of lands on the moral
spectrum or the moral compass you know
where that points versus ivy's
and this season is really going to focus
a lot on ivy and her sort of uh
embracing her inner villain
and uh you know creating uh harley kind
of initially inspiring ivy to find her
confidence uh to follow her her passion
which in in this case is to essentially
uh terraform all of gotham back to its
prehistoric uh days therefore
eradicating uh all of humanity within
the confines of the city at least
initially and uh yeah and how does
harley like ultimately feel about that
um yeah i love that and also i love that
she calls it eden with an eye i thought
yeah i thought that was very funny ivy's
never good at naming things or anything
off the cuff she just is one-liners
improviser that there is i can relate to
that very deeply
um so i just want to talk about one
thing that i absolutely love which is
the bane voice
james adomian i could do that bane voice
forever and never be sick of it um how
do you decide what you want to pull from
you know live action and what aspects do
you want to like that are iconic to a
certain character what do you
what goes into that process or are you
guys just like this is a hilarious voice
we gotta use it i think it's if we can
figure out what the comedic angle is
that has legs right like there's
sometimes you can do things with
characters where that's gonna be funny
for about five minutes and then what's
that going to be for the entire run of
the show as does this character have
legs and with bane
just this idea of this like i remember
when shane glines who was
who was um he's the character designer
of harley and he designed bain and i and
when i saw the first design of bane i
was like oh this is so good how did you
come up with this and he was like i just
bane seems to me like a guy who like
doesn't do leg day he does like he only
works out his upper body
and i was like oh yeah that's that
[ __ ] guy like he's like you know he's
he's this
this sort of like self-conscious self a
little bit pedantic
like
sort of dude who who's super jacked and
has a temper and and it was just like oh
there's so much to like mine out of this
guy so i think like in those like
smaller characters it is like is there a
comedic angle to this like this season
there's a lot of nora freeze
uh and nora is like another character
where our comedic angle was like she's
been frozen for 20 years
and now she wants to [ __ ] party and
like she's got a bunch of like issues
she's not dealing with
because she's just deciding to party
instead
yeah it's hard too because dc's kind of
given us carte blanche at this point to
kind of do whatever we want with most of
the characters and so it's just
talking it to death in the writer's room
ad nauseum to really find out it's it's
alchemy ultimately
yeah i love it i love what you create so
it is gold um i really want to know you
know working with so many of these
actors that aren't traditionally voice
actors you know you had alfred molina
you had um giancarlo esposito alan tudyk
who i love as clay face another voice
that is just amazing how do you how do
you convince these actors to work with
you or do they come to you like what's
this what's the story
um well uh
you know it started with season one i
think it started once we had kaylee um
as harley i think it it it gave a sense
of maybe i don't know um
cachet right that that like other actors
who are traditionally like on camera or
like interested in doing it and kind of
like stunt casting it a little bit and
once we had like kaylee and lake
then we were able to
just call up like our actor friends who
we've worked with before like we worked
with chris maloney on a live-action fox
comedy for a year and we're like hey
chris what do you think about this take
on this unhinged take on uh
jim gordon he was like i like it he was
he's so into it he's like he and he's
somebody who yeah has not done a lot of
voice stuff before like to the point
where like when we were shooting the
pilot diedrick bader we had him and
diedrich bader who voices batman on the
show in the same room which is rare for
us in the same recording booth and
dedrick had to like tell chris not to
like walk away from the microphone
because he's like just he's just acting
it out he's you know walking it out he's
like blocked it out like and so he's
doing the scene i've never seen somebody
crack himself up as much as chris when
he's doing unhinged maloney he's like
i'm just so giddy
[Laughter]
um but yeah it was just it was a
combination of like yeah having like
kaylie's cachet
uh being able to to call up actors that
we worked with before ron funches and
alan tudyk we worked with together on uh
powerless
dean laurie who was our co-creator had
worked with tony hale
on arrested development and so yeah and
wanda sykes uh was a friend of his as
she voiced queen of fables um yeah uh we
were just lucky
i mean i love it i love getting to see
the voices christopher maloney is indeed
hilarious you can tell that he
he loves that role as a he is very
jim gordon yeah he is gordon to me it
makes sense like that character just
makes sense when i first thought i was
like yes yeah he's seen some bad
ptsd and be like totally unhinged yeah i
mean his crush his man crush on batman
is like everything to me um so i love
that in this in the story you can kind
of dig really deep into character
development but also have these really
like funny body jokes how do you balance
that and not you know lean too far into
one direction or the other we when we
start in the writers room we always
start with like what's the emotional
story we're telling right in every
episode like what's this episode really
about and and so once we kind of like
figure out like here is the emotionally
resonant story we're telling which like
when you hear it as you're pitching it
out it look will oftentimes sound very
dramatic when we're like talking about
it in the writer's room but then once we
have it then it's like okay then what is
the comedic engine that will drive this
episode so that we can tell this story
so like in the fourth episode of the
show
the of this season there's like a they
go to like an eyes wide shut court
corvalle's like [ __ ] party and
and in that episode it is a it is a
moment when harley and i have probably
like one of their larger
more emotional conversations and that's
kind of what our show could do is like
we can do these crazy things but as long
as there's emotional grounding in the
episode
it'll work yeah but like
with the aforementioned [ __ ] party we've
been waiting to do that episode for like
three seasons we like i think it was
jameson borack who's one of our writers
uh had pitched it like season one and we
were like we love it we love it but we
can't figure out an organic way to bring
it in and then season three it was like
that's the one yeah that's the way there
it is it slid right in if there was ever
a group to do an orgy it would be the
court of owls so i yeah it felt right
makes a lot of sense um i love the bat
family harvey guillen is is just amazing
as nightwing i love the the like emo
voice that he has i think it's just it's
astounding um how did you get him how
did you cast him what was that situation
like was it another like we know a
friend who knows a friend no that one we
heard a lot of people for it right we
did yeah warner brothers casting um
uh convinced him to read for it i don't
even know if they had to convince him he
was just i think he was excited to do it
and it was it felt like a no-brainer
once we heard his read yeah um yeah and
we wanted to do the sort of um
you know brooding emo
titans version of the titans the show
version you know the whole [ __ ] batman
version of nightwing and you know
explore what would happen if he returned
to the bat cave with the ecosystem
having changed now the batgirl is a new
uh addition to the family and he's never
met her before and he feels like he's
being pushed out he's very insecure
about that
um and yeah so like their their sort of
chemistry is off
uh because of nightwing's return i love
that scene i love that we get to see
macaroni again as well yeah
the real joy um i want to know also
james gunn getting him
to play himself and also have some great
scenes with clayface uh
how did how did that come about and also
did you inspire him to make a actual
thomas wayne biopic in the future
we're not allowed to talk about that
last part
uh but stick around saturday in hall h
they'll be announcing it no uh you know
we knew he was a fan of the show
um he had he tweeted about it very
generously um yeah without us ever
having spoken to him he was just a fan
and uh we happened to follow each other
on twitter i had never spoken to him
before i dm'd him out of the blue and i
said hey you know shot in the dark
big fans here's what we're thinking
about doing and i'm not kidding within
15 minutes he had responded i'm in
here's my reps information and then like
two weeks later voice directing him
remotely he was up in vancouver shooting
peacemaker and uh we had him for like an
hour and we just knocked out everything
that uh he did in the season he was
fantastic he's a really funny improviser
i mean next thing is getting john cena
on as a peacemaker right
there we go
i mean i'm i'm also free to do voices if
you would like
um so you know this season i love that
we get more of the bat family i love
that we get more batman also um
how did you decide to expand beyond just
because obviously this is the show's
called harley quinn but i love that we
get to you know explore more of the
characters how did you decide you know
okay this is the season we want to do
this or this is the scene we want to do
that
again i think it starts from like
thematically what do we want what do we
find interesting about harley and ivy
and these characters
you know over the course of an entire
season like how do we want them to grow
and i think the big thing for us was
like
okay well
how do you how do you exist in a good
relationship when you've only been in
bad ones and what habits you take from
those bad ones and put into your good
ones that start to [ __ ] up your good
ones right and i think like the big idea
we were thinking about was like oh
harley only knows one way to be in a
relationship which is like
nothing she wants matters it only
matters what my partner wants and i'm
gonna put everything into them right and
that worked with the joker because he
was a narcissist but
ivy is not that and so it was we were
like oh let's chart this arc of
what it's like for harley to realize i
might want something different from my
partner and can i still exist
uh in this relationship if we want
different things i'm glad that you said
that they'll they won't break up under
your uh under your
your
kingdom
stewardship i was like what is the word
um because i was definitely a little bit
worried i was like oh are they gonna are
they gonna go backwards but no but i do
like that there's you know struggles
there still in a burgeoning relationship
um with so many exciting characters like
new characters coming in how do you guys
decide like when it comes to like comic
books what you're gonna pull from like
stories that you're going to pull from
what is the thought process or are you
just like
wouldn't it be cool if we had you know
man bat in the scene or something like
that
i i think generally um we do look to
the books um you know past and present
for like you know kind of
general inspiration like
you know especially with the first
couple of seasons
when
we were looking to kind of like pull
from the hits right and so like just one
example was like no man's land right
such a huge event in in dc publishing um
that just felt so right for our story
and it just it it just became um
again like it was like this
serendipitous thing where you know we we
we do have writers who are knowledgeable
about the comics who are on staff and
then we have a lot of just comedy nerds
but you know we can put our heads
together and and uh and and between the
you know the handful of us kind of
have pretty much like uh an encyclopedic
knowledge of and of course dc is helpful
with that as well if we ever get stuck
for like a character or something that
we can pull from but
yeah if you know if something feels
right and something feels like familiar
in a good way but we can kind of put our
own spin on it like the no man's land
thing um that we did it
in season two um
yeah we'll just we'll just do it because
they have i mean
it's like people have asked us before
like
are you guys going to create original
characters like harley obviously
originated in the comics and like
that was we never set out to do that
because
there's thousands of characters that we
can pull from so what's the point
especially when we can put our own spin
on things
so uh
yeah but then also sometimes yes we want
man bat in a scene because he voices
i do voice man
well you know you gotta this is one
person who would like more man bat
um more courtroom seems with amanda yeah
uh just to close everything out you know
i want to bring up the whole batman and
catwoman's scene that we uh we we
unfortunately didn't get to see uh i
know that you guys like to push the
envelope when it comes to those kinds of
things are there any more scenes that
they were like that wb was like maybe
maybe we don't want to go in that
direction or dc was maybe we don't want
to go in that direction or they like you
know people seem to respond very
positively to that idea and you know dc
kind of lets us uh
they they gave us the rope to hang
ourselves with um
and uh i would say that
um this year we never really got any
pushback uh this year they were really
supportive there was a couple times that
we pushed we like pulled ourselves back
from moments that would have been like
maybe too far
um but uh yeah i i think like
dc gets what the show is and they like
that the show sort of like has this sort
of irreverent sense of humor and
and really it's like they give us the
keys of the castle i mean it's pretty
amazing well amazing and i want to thank
you guys for talking with me and i can't
wait for everybody to see season three
of harley quinn
thank you